sometimes when we talk about a political
issue on the show or a legal issue or a
socio-cultural issue we talk in really
specific technicalities everything is
couched in a variety of details and in
sort of nuanced and sophisticated ways
with caveats and ifs and ands and buts
and very often that's actually the right
analysis to do we want to be careful we
want to be thorough we want to be
detailed and the problem with it is that
sometimes I as much as anybody else will
end up kind of getting lost in those
details and I will to apply a common
proverb or term or metaphor or analogy I
will miss the forest for the trees we
forget that we're in a forest because
we're busy trying to count and measure
every single tree for example and Hilary
Clinton actually did something clever
last night on the Rachel Maddow Show and
this may come as a shock to many people
in our audience but I'm not a Hillary
fan and I don't watch Rachel Maddow's
show I don't really watch MSNBC the last
time I talked about Rachel Maddow was
years ago when she bogus ly hyped up
having Trump's tax returns and what she
had was like the first page of Trump's
oh five returned which had nothing
interesting in it other than showing
that most of the tax that Trump paid was
as a result of the alternative minimum
tax so people know Hillary's well to my
right I don't watch these shows or
whatever but this is actually a pretty
interesting clip Hillary Clinton said
last night on the Rachel Maddow Show
hold on a second let's step back for a
moment in terms of Trump and Russia and
Muller from was collusion or obstruction
established which evidence threshold do
these different legal terms allude to
exactly how partisan was William bars
handling of this entire thing Hillary
Clinton steps back from the trees and
says let's look at the forest for a
second and she lays out a really great
hypothetical imagine if a Democrat went
on live television and said China if
you're listening
go and get Trump's taxes and then hours
later the IRS got hacked and Trump's
taxes were released and we found out
that it was actually China who
hacked and provided those taxes to some
third party like a WikiLeaks sort of
organization Hillary Clinton is stepping
back from the trees and remembering that
we're in the forest take a look at what
she said last night since Russia is
clearly backing Republicans why don't we
ask China to back us I hear by tonight
ask China that's right and not only that
China if you're listening why don't you
get Trump's tax returns I'm sure our
media would richly reward you now
according to the Muller report that is
not conspiracy because it's done right
out in the open so if after this
hypothetical Democratic candidate says
this on your show
within hours all of a sudden the IRS
offices are bombarded with incredibly
sophisticated cyber tools looking for
Trump's tax returns and then extracts
them and then passes them to whatever
the new WikiLeaks happens to be and they
start being unraveled and disclosed
nothing wrong with that so the point of
playing this is not to praise Hillary I
mean I thought that she was a bad
candidate and she's well to my right the
point of this is not to to revisit the
idea that Trump personally colluded with
Putin I told you 13 months ago go back
and look that it is not going to be the
outcome of the Moller probe that's not
how these things work it's not Trump
getting on the phone with Putin and
saying how can we work together to help
me win this is just a good reminder that
sometimes we've got to zoom out to
understand the picture of what's going
on and the context and get away from the
minutia that often becomes the focus in
many analyses of the Moller report now I
can't believe that I have to do what I'm
about to do I bet some of you maybe even
fell for this unfortunately there are a
ton of right-wing news outlets and
so-called commentators and analysts who
seized on the clip I just played for you
which is Hillary Clinton with a
hypothetical thought experiment right
and they are claiming that Hillary
called
for China to hack Trump's taxes okay can
you imagine being so
disconnected from reality and so lost
that you fall for the claim that when
Hillery says here's a thought experiment
that she is actually calling for China
to hack Donald Trump's taxes and if the
right has successfully bamboozled you
into thinking that then I feel sorry for
you
but but I feel obligated to just mention
that there are actually people on the
right claiming that that clip was
Hillary publicly calling for the illegal
hacking of Donald Trump's taxes by China
and the funny thing about that is the
people who are attacking Hillary for the
thought experiment don't seem to care
that Donald Trump actually did it like
Trump actually called for Russia to hack
Hillary in the DNC and then Russia did
and then they gave the data to WikiLeaks
which Trump used to say that he loved
but now all of a sudden claims to barely
even remember who they were and the only
conclusion that I came to after
reviewing the reactions to this clip
from right-wing media was that we're in
trouble
we're in trouble as a country were in
trouble as a society and we are so far
down the rabbit hole of a total lack of
critical thinking and media literacy
that I I wish I could be more optimistic
about the future but I'm not based on
how many people fall for this stupid
mischaracterization of what Hillary
Clinton did last night disclaimer I
didn't vote for her in the primary and
she's to my right and this is not
talking about how great Hillary Clinton
is she just made an interesting point
last night if you love learning new
things you probably want to check this
out the david pakman show today is
sponsored by Skillshare and we're giving
you two entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a
class on introductory watercolor
painting I'm still not good but I am
learning and you can access the entire
library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video